[Music]
[Music]
people should not be worried the city is
secure anyone who is going to create
disorder in the city will be dealt with
strongly the security of the city is
guaranteed and it is not going to be
attacked we will stand strongly do not
be influenced by any propaganda
everything is normal
[Music]
[Music]
i understand now as we've tried to speak
with various government ministers they
say that we are inside the palace at the
moment finalizing a transition plan we
understand that former president karzai
intends to take whatever transition plan
they come up with to doha and present it
to muller baroda who is the taliban's
political chief where he will either
accept or not accept it on behalf of the
movement now the government's really
against the wall here they have very
little leverage left the city is
encircled the taliban have picked up
provinces overnight directly to the east
and cut them off from pakistan through
talking crossing they're cut off uh cut
them off from the west by taking wardak
province and they took loda loga just to
the south on friday so they are fully
surrounded and now the taliban has taken
districts within kabul province and a
knocking at the gates of kabul
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you